uh good afternoon welcome back uh to the
final session of uh
the
simon's 10th anniversary workshop
symposium uh we saved some of the best
stocks for the last
uh we start off with
our beloved christos papademitro uh
who's
focus the computational lens on so many
different areas uh markets biology and
today is tell us about
uh how does brain make language
[Applause]
many things can everybody hear me
okay so um
i just want to point out that what is
happening now
is uh nothing short of miraculous uh
almost unexplainable i create uh air
waves in this space
and these air waves come to your ear
and they translate it into words somehow
by by your auditory cortex
and then the real miracle happens that
these words
are understood by you
are and they form
hierarchies
which you store away
and if i'm very lucky you will never
forget
okay
uh
many some of you are i know are students
of the brain
but i know that this puzzles you also
okay you know this is not normal okay
brains are not supposed to do something
like that okay this is by far
the most incredible thing that that any
brain has done
and
i mean we know something about it we
have known for since 150 years that
there are two areas uh
broca's area and wernicke's area uh back
then we thought that brokaw is about the
generation of speech what i'm doing now
where are various about comprehension of
speech what you are doing now
but since then we wisened up and we know
that
broca's area is about
the structure of the sentence whereas
wernicke's area is about the word choice
okay so
but frankly we don't know much about
that i mean even though
uh i have this annoying thing happening
in my screen uh
that is trying to connect me with the
wi-fi i don't know if other speakers had
that okay so
and the the very exciting thing about
what's happening with language is that
we have had some amazing experiments so
i'm going to i'm going to show you an
experiment that
really impressed me and sort of changed
the course of my research so basically
what they did is they uh
they had a recording uh heard by
thousands of patients of
of subjects
in six different languages in different
circumstances but i mean they and
the recording was uh
single-syllable words in the
corresponding language uh
dictated at four hertz something like
this
okay and then what they did is they took
all this data
they milled them together they put
through a fourier transform and of
course no surprise this came out okay
there was a huge peak at four hertz
because four times every second
these subjects have to do the same thing
which is uh fetch this world and see if
they understand it and if they fit
together it fits together with other
words
and then they did something really
clever they just repeated the experiment
except this time every four words make
sense
and guess what happened now
there were three picks
there was one pick at four because the
same thing happened but there was a peak
at one hurts which means that once every
second
these people were doing something
different which is what
they were creating a sentence
and twice every second they were
creating a phrase
okay so here is what i think what was
happening
okay
so four years ago i was at the simons
institute and there was an nlp
workshop
and the chairman of the century i gave a
talk about something else and the
chairman of the century was was chris
manning and after that we had lunch
together the the new the berkeley museum
had opened and they had this nice
cafeteria
and uh
during this life i did something really
weird i i left my my fork i looked chris
bunny
in the eye and asked him the following
something like for the love of god chris
do we have trees in our brain
and uh chris manning
thought for a minute
he told me yeah
i think we have created our brain and i
mean i chose manning because in my book
he would be
among students of language the least
likely to be a terrific okay you know to
believe that we have treason our brain
you know after that i mean
this really made me think
okay here is what here is what's going
on
uh
language works at four hertz
our brain in this area which is the
language organ works at 50 hertz
so this means that these trees
are built in 12 steps in 12 parallel
steps
okay
for every 12 spikes you must create a
new layer of the tree
i mean how can you can you imagine that
so there is a there is a there is a
somewhere over here there is a dynamical
system which consists of neurons and
synapses okay
and it's pulsates sort of you know at 50
hertz
and every 12 pulses
you have a new layer of the tree
i don't think anybody knows how this is
done i mean i i
i believe it's
really incredible that this is possible
okay but it must be possible okay
here is another experiment so you know
before before we go along i mean
they read to patients with fmri this
time
pairs of sentences like
the ball hit the track the truck hit the
ball and then noticed that the word ball
was recorded at different places in the
in the brain in the two in the two
sentences okay this means that we have a
different
center a different place for a subject
of different place for objects okay
so
this is what i'm saying is that this is
an incredibly difficult problem to
understand how this is done all right
and uh
[Music]
keep watching so you know i'm going to
i'm going to
i will have a theory of how this is done
okay we have done it okay
and and uh
so but amino we're now looking at a very
hard problem i mean and i mean
think about it you are theoretical
computer scientist we see a hard problem
what do we do
we generalize it okay you know we
we look at a harder problem
which is uh
how does the mind emerge for the brain
okay so this is uh this is a very well
known text in cognitive neuroscience
this is a very well known known resource
book in in
in experimental neuroscience
and the you know there is not telling
the distance between the two okay there
is a there is a huge gap in scale of
course but of course there is a huge gap
in experimental methodology experimental
animals focus and so on okay
and
and in fact
one of the heroes my hero of uh this uh
you know while actually we were we were
at simon's uh during a
a semester on
uh computation in the brain
when uh
uh
richard axel uh published the uh
uh an opinion piece uh in the neuron
where he said the following we do not
have a logic for the transformation of
neural activity into thought this is
exactly the gap that i was telling you
okay we don't have
a
system that mediates the two okay
i view discerning this logic as the most
important future direction in
neuroscience okay when we heard when you
read this i mean with santos venpala
and you know we we were here
we were organizers of organizers of this
semester
we felt that we were blessed by the pope
okay because this is exactly what this
is exactly what we have been working on
okay
so
the question is
you know there are two if you think
about it there are two surprises here
one surprise is that axel uses the word
logic okay which to my ear sounds like
he's looking for a formal comp system
which is ultimately computational okay
and you should know actually sort of you
know a quintessential empirical
scientist okay you know so a
great experimentalist uh the second
surprise
is that uh four years later
only santos and i are working on this
okay you know so so we have you know we
have we are the only ones who have a
hypothesis of what this this logic is
going to be and then i'm going to show
you
so i mean the question is where does
computation in the brain happen okay
molecules of course it happens in more
use spiking uracil synapses sure
dendrites i mean that's the input device
of the of the cell of course it happens
in the drys i mean we know that so you
know
it happens in the whole brain also okay
because you have cognitive scientists
who run experiments and then they tell
you you see the subjects as they act as
if their brain was executing this
program okay so you know there is there
is in all these layers there is there is
a computation except in the middle okay
except between spiking neurons the
synapses and the whole brain okay so
what
what can be there okay so and our
proposal is
that uh
there is uh
there is a layer
we call it the assembly calculus
which is assemblies of neurons and their
operations i'm going to explain what
these are
and
the point of this
is that
what do we want in such a logic okay
that as as axel uh asked for it you want
to be implementable by neurons and
synapses
and to implement
cognitive activity
okay so this is what we're after
all right everybody's name
uh by the way what you know to explain
what assemblies are many of you in the
70s and 80s neuroscientists were telling
us that there is something something
called the grandmother cell every time
we think of it we think of our
grandmother okay
you know so in the 90s uh people
realized so you know that's not possible
okay because i mean every neuron talks
to tens of thousands of other neurons
okay if there was one grandmother cell
there would be no grandmother okay so so
now they call them the jennifer aniston
cells all right
and because we know you know sort of you
know we found them in people so we
showed them pictures of of jennifer
aniston and neurons
started going like crazy okay and and
what happened then is you know they do
back of the developer calculation we we
recorded from uh 60 neurons out of 10
million
uh we saw 200 pictures
we got a hit
so there must be not one jane tyranison
but maybe thirty thousand generation
cells okay that together they fire every
time you see a picture of the influence
okay so so by the way after this talk
you are not only going to have jennie
ferrance on sales
but you are going to have jennifer lance
from cell cells
think about it okay but don't go that
way okay
all right so
these these are samples of cells we call
them assemblies what are assemblies
first uh they were they were conjectured
in you know 70 something years ago by
donald hebb okay so you know the uh the
father of cognitive neuroscience uh
then you know for 50 something years
they were looking for them in animals
but i sort of know the recording
technology was such that they could not
yet
find find them beyond statistical doubt
uh sort of busy in harris
found them in the beginning of the
century my colleague at columbia uh
rafa used to found them soon after uh
busaki calls them in his popular book
assemblies are the alphabet of the brain
okay so i mean of those of you sort of
in all hands in artificial intelligence
where you remember the dilemma
is intelligent symbolic or sub-symbolic
okay this is where they to meet okay so
you know that's where many neurons get
together and create symbols okay and
that's why they're called the alphabet
of the brain okay
so
an assembly is a large and densely
interconnected in other words you know
the brain is a sparse thing right so
assemblies are a little more maybe twice
or three times more dense than than than
uh than the environment okay uh and
that's a that's that's a computer
science problem if you think about it i
mean how do you find in a sparse random
graph then sub graph okay so you know
but but the brains know how to solve it
i mean we can talk about this later uh
so it's of excitatory neurons in a brain
area who's firing in a pattern instant
amount we're thinking of a particular
memory concept person name word episode
et cetera okay so these are assemblies
assemblies are not
our fantasy okay they are old news
everybody knows everybody knows the
brain works this way uh
what is not the mystery is how okay and
and uh with santos and and went with and
with uh actually wolfgang was another uh
uh
co-organizer of that of that semester
damien troposki is is my student at
columbia uh we wrote this uh this paper
explaining why we believe that there is
a logic
whose
data objects are assemblies okay and it
has a lot of operations algebraic
operations you call them the the
assembly categories and and we believe
that this is the missing logic
so the assembly hypothesis says this
that there is the intermediate level
brain computation exactly in the place
where i showed you it's implicated in
higher cognitive functions such as
reasoning planning language storytelling
math science music and so on the good
stuff
and assemblies of neurons are its basic
representation is data type right
and with it come operations and
operations are things like projection
merge associate inhibit this inhibit and
so on so
let me show you just
just a projection operator
imagine that you have an area a another
brain area b
and there you have an assembly called x
sitting the blue assembly sitting in in
area a okay that's
30 000 neurons let's say that every time
you think of uh of of your dog uh it
it it it fires okay
and now
uh you have another area b and there is
uh
synaptic connectivity a huge bipartite
random graph between area a and area b
okay and of course there is uh there is
a recurrent connectivity in area b okay
there are there are there are
if there is a random graph in area b as
well
okay
if x fires about a dozen times
uh
a stable copy x prime will emerge in be
a second assembly which will be a copy
of the first assembly a projection of
the first assembly
and uh from now on if x fires then x
prime will follow suit okay so these
things are in are connected
all right
so the question is all right i mean i'm
saying so but i mean how do we know all
right i'll tell you how we know all
right i mean pay attention for the next
slide because
not many talks have this slide okay you
know i'm going to tell you a
mathematical model of the brain all
right so
uh what is what is the brain the brain
is a is a is a set of a set of a set of
bra set of areas brain areas
and uh each one of them contains neurons
think of it as 10 million okay
and uh
in each brain area at each moment we
imagine that the the fire in distinct
steps which is
not what happens in reality but it's not
a very distortive assumption okay we
imagine discrete times steps
in each step k neurons from each area
fire okay only k out of them think of k
as like square root of n
okay
3 000
and
some pairs of areas are connected by
bipartite graphs okay these these these
red arrows and all are recurrently
connected all have
non-bipartite graphs okay
all right
simple
enough
so
uh
neurons firing discrete step
in each so in each area
at each time unit
the k neurons that have the size the
higher synaptic inputs from the other
neurons either in the same area or in
other areas from the previous firing
those are selected to fire okay and this
is a sort of you know an important uh
part of our model that models inhibition
okay inhibition is
the care that the brain takes that it
doesn't blow up okay so you know that
only a few neurons in each area are fire
uh
connections uh
between areas the red arrows can be
inhibited or disinhibited whole areas
can inhibit be inhibited disinhibited
and also there is plasticity so you know
the last the last trick
if there is an
edge from i to j
and i fires and the next step j fires
then there is a weight in this j is this
edge i j
and and and this weight will be
multiplied will be increased by 10
percent let's say
okay
so these are this is all nothing else
okay i have not and basically
we are thinking these are the intended
values and if you think about it i mean
this model has three main ideas which is
randomness okay run it works by
randomness okay without trying to work
selection
and the plasticity okay if you think
about it these are the three forces of
nature okay the three main ideas in
nature
and in life
and
assemblies and their operations are an
emerging property of this dynamical
system okay we don't i you know an
assembly is not an axiom and a separate
theorem okay assemblies happen in this
system
happen by themselves if you let it go it
will have they will happen all right so
you know if you think about it i mean
think of a computer chip
it is a dynamical system like this okay
there is this
mess of of atoms of of lattices
that are intertwined and electrons
between them okay but the point is
that we have you know there there is
there is a class of attractors of the
system okay it's an emergent property
that we call bits
okay and this make us able to compute
i think that the brain
it's these attractors that enable us to
compute okay the assemblies
all right
cool uh
so the assemblies are real in the
following
sensors
that they're they correspond to
behaviors of
the assembly operations okay the
operations that we use you know the
assembly categories
i you know
i'm i believe they are real because
first of all we have either observed
them or they would explain better
experiments
and
they can probably compile be compiled
down to the activity of neurons and
synapses when i say probably
i mean either through mathematical
theorems or excessive simulations on
this model
or simulations in other models
that are
asynchronous
and more neurorealistic okay so you know
so we we we
we
look at sort of you know the the latest
model neurons that that they have and
and we simulate these operations and
they work so
the recap is that we have all these
operations these are control operations
that we need six or seven operations the
question is how powerful is the system
and it turns out to have a result that
it can perform arbitrarily and over k
space computations if you think about
that n over k space means n over k
parallel steps okay
so this is a lot of computation
okay hundred parallel steps is a lot of
rules
how many assemblies uh so the excellent
question there is there is uh there is a
limit there is a there is a capacity for
every area it's like
sort of n over k
within log factors
there is a capacity
yeah oh yeah absolutely absolutely you
know in in our in our language area each
one of us has about a hundred thousand
assemblies that represent words
okay and i'm going to talk about them
yeah thank you
uh cool
so here's the challenge as i said
can hire cognitive functions be carried
out by this framework so you know so
once two years ago we published our
paper and since then we have been
working trying to show
that cognitive functions okay like
planning reasoning learning language
okay so that this can be carried out by
assemblies that you can we can have
programs in the and also credible
programs in the in the in the cultures
not not just sort of uh concocted
programs in the culture so i mean also
and this brings us back to this to this
original question how does the language
organ work and one of the things that we
have learned is that
sort of you know there is there is
people have been studying for a long
time more mostly cognitive scientists a
cognitive linguists and neurolinguists
and so what what we know is that we have
these areas that seem to be important
word selection
structure trees
and there is here a big area in the
medial temporal lobe which is called the
lexicon okay where as i said before we
have a lot of assemblies that that
encode represent words okay
and each one of us seems to have
uh hundreds of thousands of this and in
fact there is a there is an amazing book
a recent book that
by a
famous german
neurolinguist
that
sub that sort of summarizes in a very
interesting way of everything we knew up
to four years ago
about about this this
thing
and basically what we know we know that
when you hear a word
activity here means that the word uh the
word
sort of is excited fires then things
happen here things happen here things
happen here okay so so we know that that
that that there is
you know people believe that that that
words are being looked up
then syntactic things uh you know the
syntactic structure of the
of the sentences is deduced and then the
syntactic tree is built okay so you know
but sorry no
there is
there is i mean if you if you there is a
page
you know a paging for the religious book
that basically
says the following you know you know so
she she she tells this story that words
happen here then something else happens
there he says but how on earth do this
part communicate
okay and she says something completely
desperate okay she says i hypothesize
that there are language mirror cells
okay mirror cells are something that we
have in our brain that every time we see
somebody move we imagine that we make
the same motion okay so you know it's
you know
and i read this this paragraph and i
said this is a neuroscientist
praying for assemblies okay
and i wrote to her and she said
that's exactly what i've been waiting
for okay so i sent her our paper and we
have written a paper since
sort of explaining why assemblies are
the right thing for language
and so you know what i'm most exciting
about excited about is i'm going to show
you an experiment that we run we have we
have written a program with assembly
calculus
we have created a dynamical system which
does exactly what i told you in the
beginning
okay it is
driven by words okay every time it hears
a word a new process starts and in the
end you have a tree
okay so we have built it
uh
the architecture is this okay we have uh
and it corresponds roughly to what uh to
what friday chip uh
uh
uh conjectures that in the
media temporal lobe there is there is a
uh
there is a
an area that has a lot of assemblies
that have words
that
there is vernicas area which may be
divided into sub-areas
we know that that the that the the
bridge between wernicke's area and
and and the medial temporal lobe
is full of uh
evolutionarily recent uh fibers okay in
other words big uh big uh
bundles of
synapses okay that that these these
bipartite graphs that i showed you
uh
and and
so this is this this is the the
uh
and basically
uh
let me show you let me show how it works
imagine so basically what it is
it is
a huge dynamical system
with uh
10 million neurons
some trillions of synapses of weighted
synapses
and and and either or not a random graph
okay
and
suppose that uh
it's a parser of english all right so
suppose the input is cats chase dogs
okay
and
it starts the the the the fiber
connecting legs with subjects is red red
means is disinhibited okay it's ready to
go okay the these uh these uh these uh
these synapses are working okay
and
basically what happens
why is that
because this is english
and the parser knows that it will see
the subject before it sees the verb the
object okay if it was german or russian
or japanese it would be something
different
okay
uh
and and and but i mean in english it's
going you know the english parser is
like it starts like this okay and and
what happens is is uh
when uh
cats is heard okay so the word cuts is
heard
this assembly fires because of the
auditory quarters knows how to excite it
and
then what happens before because this
pulsates a dozen times or more
and this is uh this is uh works this
means that there is going to be uh
there's going to be a projection okay so
you know a copy of cats is going to uh
be created there in the subject area
okay and this records the fact that cats
seems to be the subject of this sentence
okay so i mean let's look at a little
more closely to the assembly for the
word cats okay it has uh several kinds
of neurons these are phonetic neurons
basically
information of how
how it sounds and how you pronounce it
okay
uh it has semantic neurons part of it
will be a bunch of plural neurons so
that this is this is a plural
form of some noun
and then importantly there are action
neurons okay what are action neurons
these are neurons
that work okay work for you they change
the inhibitive inhibit inhibited and
disinhibited areas and synapses and and
and fibers okay they change the state of
the system
most uh most uh
inhibitory neurons what they do is uh
they basically uh uh that they do
firework okay they
they're they're firefighters uh they say
not
come down but this there are some
inhibitory neurons sometimes called in
the neurons that change the say the
state they inhibit inhibit the
disinhibited state of the system and
these are the the red neurons the action
neurons and every word has some of these
all nouns have the same red neurons okay
they know that they're nouns so the the
red neurons the action set of a word
represent its syntactic role okay
uh
and so
uh
then
uh
then chase
uh is the next word okay it's heard
the corresponding uh the corresponding
assembly fires and what it does
it it
this inhibits
the
fiber from uh lex to verb and also from
subject to that because it knows that
the subject must be already there
okay
and
as a result
the chase is is is
is
projected here and what is this
chase knows that it's not just a verb
but it is a transitive verb and
therefore now an object is coming so
it's opening the fiber to the object
area okay and so when
[Music]
dogs comes
uh it's projected
and uh
the sentence has been passed okay so
there is the period that says okay we're
done with the sentence now what's the
question what what okay there is here's
a fair question okay you went through
this dance how do i know that the
sentence was parsed okay
here is how
uh
the synaptic weight connections between
uh the assemblies
in the in in this area
uh form a valid dependency tree okay
which is the parts of this sentence okay
and dependency three is not just what
chomsky called grammars but it is the it
is the the the tool of choice for nlp
okay this is how the the dispensary
grammars this is how the parts and it
turns out that is the right thing to do
for for for for uh
you know
this is the most most
direct convenient thing to parse of two
parts in in this in this
in this device
uh and the point is that
afterwards we can retrieve it okay by
further uh by further assembly calculus
operations and and really show that yes
it parsed correctly
okay
so
what i want to make sure everybody
understands
is this it is implemented exclusively
through the firing of neurons and
synapses
uh and and and
through the dynamical system okay
and and
and uh
in other words there are no variables no
loops no conditionals just neurons the
synapses of the dynamical system okay
nothing else is going on all right
and it is driven
by the input words
and after the process after the
processing the parts will be retrieved
and the code is available
the paper was
presented the day before yesterday in
acl in ireland
okay
so it passes simple sentences not cut
sage dogs by the good parts descendants
the young couple in the next house saw
the little white car of the main suspect
quite clearly okay this it would find
parsley is fine okay
and how he has pars thousands of
sentences like that
uh in our experiment without a single
amino everything i know about assemblies
say that with high probability it will
parse uh we have not seen you know we
have we have run thousands of
examples and we have not seen a mishap
uh it's it's the speed is about the
speed i'm talking about i'm talking now
and uh
i mean there is much more work to do uh
sentence a bedding policeman i'm going
to tell you tell you something about
about and if in fact we have a simple
russian parker parser running okay so
that's uh
and there is also japanese parser by by
colleagues in japan chinese parser
hungarian parser
uh
so
uh
so
let me make a parenthesis and i'm almost
done okay uh it's a fun parenthesis for
with that hassle that has some pcs
incidentally all of this
is tcs okay you know because sort of you
know the theorems that that santos and i
proved about and our colleagues
about about assemblies are sort of
frankly difficult theorems in random
graphic okay so you know and and and and
but i mean i i only
mentioned them once in this but i mean
so but i mean
look at this
that's a catch right i mean
cats when they're fearless chase dogs
okay how do you do this okay you know i
know how to do cats chase dogs but how
do you do recursion okay so
what is needed for recursion sort of you
know and our you know we thought very
hard about this problem for more than a
year and our final solution was the
following what you do when you see a
comma the comma where you assume that
you have a lot of hints when you see a
coma you realize that
an embedded sentence uh starts and you
parse it you you say okay when okay so
that's that's a dependent sentence they
are fearless fine i passed it another
comma so now you go back to cats okay
and you touch it and as a result you
restore the state when you had aware of
the comma
okay then you ignore the things between
the commas and you continue parts
okay so this is what we did
and we know so here is some automata
theory uh
so far the parser was a finite state
automaton okay why is that because the
state is the
the graph of the disinhibited fibers
okay that's the state of the of the
device so it's a finite state machine
exponential state but still
and
what we have here is is an enhancement
of that which you call the fallback
machine
at any point it can return when it sees
the second comma to the most recent
marked symbol and mark it and continue
okay so so basically we enhance it with
this extra capability
okay
uh are you ready for this uh this gives
you the context free languages
okay
so amino realize what this means okay
that
70 years ago
chomsky
wanted to understand human language
and conjecture
that context free language is the right
is the right
is the right
formulation
this was criticized up and down okay
it's too generous because many many
context-free
features are not needed and it's also
too restricted because there are
features of language that are not
context-free okay so it has been
abandoned and grammars were still
still
an important part of chomsky's theory
but only
a very limited
kind of grammar was used okay only a
sentence can be a noun phrase followed
by a birth phrase nothing else okay all
right so
60 something years later
a bunch of computer scientists were
trying to see how to implement recursion
okay
and they came up with
a formulation of what has been to be
done
that coincides with context
grammars okay so this is this is a
difficult theorem okay
to explain to you how difficult it is
uh mkhitaryan calculus is a quota okay
we have to recruit megaliths right
okay so
is this the neural base of languages
okay so you know so
if any of you are familiar with
linguistics if there were linguists in
here by now we have heard cries of
blasphemy okay okay so you know you are
not supposed to ask this question okay
okay this question is supposed to hang
so you know without that ever been asked
but i mean here here's the point a bold
experiment entitles you to ask such
questions right i mean
because there is no other hypothesis
okay maybe this is
the neural basis of language this is
what chomsky and chrome skins have been
looking and if so how do babies populate
it okay how do
they gave they get these these labels
and these assemblies okay so and this is
our holy grail this is what we are
working on next
uh
and and basically we are uh i mean i
already read it because the amount of
time uh
we are trying to build a biologically
possible language acquisition okay where
basically on input
uh an
organ tabula organ with some
capabilities and try to keep them at the
minimum
plus
baby intended talk
and not too much so you know as as much
as it is reasonable to for a mother to
uh to to give her child the first two
years of life uh
you want to
have an output a functionalized language
organ ready to parse and regenerate
okay if you wish the assemblies
with election sets okay because that's
that's that's what we
okay um
we do other things we we we assemblies
can learn
uh again predict they can do reasoning
they can do planning they can do
the blocks world uh
okay so
to conclude uh
the you know studying this this problem
uh is by far uh the most fascinating and
the most difficult thing that i have
done okay so you know it uh
it
it would be
impossible without the simon says
i believe that up that assemblies are
the assembly hypothesis
is
a viable answer
to
what to what axel is asking
and
the pastor experiment has brought us
close to amazing questions
our assembly is the seed of access logic
or excel's logic
okay
and these are my collaborators
and
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
by the way this is the carp
i have a question
um
are there observable
just just stick to language processing
which because
we can all relate to it
languages differ in whether the verb is
at the end the verb is in the middle
yeah
languages have different dynamics do
experiments on the brain show those
dynamics and do they reflect absolutely
yeah such characteristics absolutely
abso absolutely so i mean this
linguistic theory is uh so i'm you know
uh there is something called language vs
order you know
svo order subject verb object so you
know all six orders exist in languages
there are many theories why the the and
of course every language i mean as i
told you we have a hungarian parser we
have a russian parser russia russian has
very weak order you can start with the
object you can start with the verb you
can start with the subject okay so you
know so we parcels okay you know so so
it's it's uh it's uh
yes i mean also these are extremely well
studied
these aspects are sort of studied like
tens of thousands of papers in
linguistics and and and uh
and uh we see them also in our work yeah
there is there is another question
christos thank you very much for the
amazing talk i have one question about
the last part so i think after that nice
talk that the most natural question was
how we
create these legs that was a question at
the end so
my first question is
is that the
is that a fear that we have a case of a
vicious cycle because then i we want to
uh
learn
you know you will create a legs that
learn legs and uh
recursion is useful but but but it's uh
it's not everywhere okay you know so no
i mean
we hope that that that you know we hope
that that we are going to show how to
how to create legs
you know so remember so you know what
what do you what the input has to be
some kind of uh grounded
baby talk okay you know and and and
um
and that would be a different part of
the head of the brain
no i mean
more parts will be involved yeah
[Music]
that's what grounded means
so uh i love this notion of an assembly
can one neuron
be in more than one assembly
absolutely
so neurons share assemblies for example
in the in in
in in the brain in in the in the legs in
the language organ uh all
all nouns have the same uh
action sets okay so so uh
neurons sorry assemblies share neurons
and this shows the commonality of the
concepts okay okay so you know and and
and uh help us associate and recall
things okay you know so this is you know
the sharing of assemblies is very
important and of neurons by assemblies
and it is sort of you know is the basis
of associative memory i believe okay
thank you sure
awesome
so um your talk was focused on language
but uh do you believe that the same
mechanisms are used for other cognitive
processes
and you know so did you focus on
language because you think it's special
or because you think
it's easier to evaluate
i think it's the hardest
uh i focused on language because i
believe is the hardest uh i mean about
reasoning for example
there are schools of cognitive
scientists who believe that reasoning is
done through language there are other
schools that say that that reasoning is
happening by assemblies directly
uh and and so you know we're working on
reasoning
about something like more basic like
recognizing
uh excellent okay you heard the talk by
bruno you know so so uh
so
i mean
visual vision
we have been it's extremely well
understood
okay so you know i mean
maybe not how we how we recognize the
predator so you know that's that's uh
that's that that's that's that's an
interesting but vision is the thing that
we have been studying for 70 years okay
the question is can we talk about
something else so you know
okay thank you christos for the
fascinating talk
next speaker